on va parler de l'actualité l'actualité
du jour c'est ce qui se passe au Conseil
des ministres et Samia le gouvernement
qui est en conseil des ministres
devraient dissoudre les soulèvement de
la terre oui ça a été annoncé hier par
Gérald Darmanin ça va être fait
aujourd'hui les soulèvements de la terre
c'est donc un mouvement qui agrégé des
organisations et des militants
écologistes pour mener des actions
contre l'accaparement des terres et
l'artificialisation des sols des actions
qui sont jugées trop violentes par le
gouvernement surtout depuis le
rassemblement de sainte Soline contre
les méga bassines c'était en mars
dernier il y a eu 200 blessés parmi les
manifestants 47 chez les gendarmes les
taux se resserre donc autour de
l'organisation hier une série
d'interpellations a eu lieu dans les
milieux militants proches des
soulèvements de la terre elle serait en
lien avec une intrusion dans une usine
du cimetier Lafarge en décembre dernier
le mouvement conteste le fondement
juridique d'une dissolution et prévient
déjà qu'un recours ultra déposé cette
dissolution fait évidemment réagir les
élus écologistes on a entendu tout à
l'heure sur ce plateau marine
tondeuillier mais également le sénateur
Thomas do su qui était comme elle à
Sainte Soline conteste vivement la
décision du gouvernement regardez moi je
trouve ça très inquiétant de la part de
ce gouvernement c'est un gouvernement
qui veut désormais dissoudre une
coalition d'opposants politiques on est
vraiment dans une dérive très grave les
soulèvements de la terre ne sont ni une
milice ni une liquefactieuse ce sont des
militants écologistes qui ont permis ces
derniers mois de mettre la lumière sur
un centre de projet
dangereux pour l'environnement et donc
qui ont joué un rôle dans notre
démocratie qui ont permis de faire des
rassemblements un peu partout en France
assez massif et donc
leur dissolution sera un président
extrêmement grave pour notre démocratie
voilà on entend un Thomas dessus à
l'image de beaucoup de politiques de
gauche pierre Jacquemin cette
dissolution elle est pas justifiée
non et je pense qu'elle devrait nous
inquiéter tous
parce que on a là des militants
à guéris souvent aux mobilisation locale
souvent mobilisée dans le cadre de
ZAD mais plus généralement lanceur
d'alerte pour beaucoup d'entre eux sur
des sur des initiatives qui finissent
d'ailleurs souvent par ne pas voir le
jour je pense à Notre-Dame-des-Landes je
pense à d'autres initiatives locales
dont Marine Tondelier a pu parler tout à
l'heure
je dis que ça devrait nous inquiéter
tous parce que il y a une forme de
criminalisation de l'action militante en
ce moment depuis quelques mois voire
quelques années mais encore plus en ce
moment après la grande mobilisation que
l'on a vécu de la réforme des retraites
mais aussi en parallèle sainte Soline le
week-end dernier le lion Turin il y a
une forme de criminalisation et Marine
tondeuilly apparaît d'intimidation c'est
vrai qu'on l'a dit beaucoup au cours de
ces derniers mois mais c'est vrai que ça
ressemble beaucoup à l'intimidation et
c'est à ce point
grave que vous voyez le l'ex efficacité
marine Tondelier ce matin de ce militant
qui se fait perquisitionner alors qu'il
n'était pas participant à l'une de ces
mobilisations ça veut dire aussi que le
système qui a été mis en place pendant
25 minutes si maintenant vous parlez en
bis de sa place lorsque n'a pas eu le
temps
des idées pierre mais Gérald Darmanin
il dit aucune cause ne justifie qu'on
blesse des policiers et des gendarmes
parce qu'on parle aussi d'attaque contre
des forces de l'ordre de la même manière
je suis désolé on ne sait pas parce
qu'il y a des éléments perturbateurs des
éléments violents dans des mobilisations
revendiquées par des associations même
si elles sont sous forme de collectifs
comme le nom de la terre que l'on doit
justifier des une criminalisation parce
que c'est vraiment de la criminalisation
dont il est question ou une dissolution
on est quand même en démocratie vous
voyez toutes les alertes toutes les
alertes
de la Défenseur des droits du Conseil de
l'Europe de la Ligue 2 de la Ligue des
droits de l'homme qui disent au
gouvernement alerte sur notre démocratie
alerte sur la répression aussi du
mouvement social et des mouvements
écologistes oui ça doit nous alerter
tous et on doit écouter ce qui nous est
dit ce qui est dit à l'étranger sur ce
qui se passe en France je finis
là-dessus parce que
Marine a pris l'exemple de ce militant
qui a été perquisitionné oui mais il y a
eu d'autres cas vous prenez ce qui s'est
passé à sainte-solines ou ailleurs
encore une fois ce week-end à Lyon Turin
un militant Français résidant en Italie
c'est vu
souscrire une ce qu'on appelle une
miyaté une interdiction administrative
du territoire alors qu'il était français
c'est totalement UBS c'est-à-dire qu'on
reprend des termes de textes entités
pour s'en prendre à des militants
écologistes
je reste tout à fait de on sait jamais
dans le quart d'heure qui vient mais
pour l'instant je reste au fait vous le
démocrate ça vous scandalise ce qui se
passe évidemment Dominique non je suis
pour la démocratie tout court ça me
scandale non ne cherchez pas mon relais
marine tondelee vous a déjà enrôlé ça
suffit alors maintenant c'est pas vous
qui allez m'enrôler pour que ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que si on écoute
marine Tondelier tout à l'heure si on a
quand on l'a écouté plutôt elle était
intéressante mais c'est un peu le
principe de on donne le bon Dieu sans
confession avec elle elle a une version
ou alors je pars en plein d'autres
expressions une version un peu simpliste
volontairement c'est c'est la militante
qui parle et vous et vous en relais en
chambre
oui oui mais je respecte je respecte
comme tel notamment mais vous en chambre
déco derrière
d'abord est-ce que la est-ce que la
est-ce que le
est-ce que sous les bancs de la Terre va
être interdit c'est très compliqué c'est
une c'est une association qui regroupe
qui n'a pas pignon sur rue il y a pas
une adresse avec où on peut aller avec
un téléphone etc elle regroupe
d'ailleurs marine tondeuilly a beaucoup
joué de ça elle regroupe des
sensibilités globalement écolo mais mais
très différente les unes des autres donc
bonne chance au gouvernement il a
affiché une attention tout le monde sait
que c'est pas on n'est pas le passage à
l'acte va être s'il y a un passage à
l'acte le passage à l'aide va être
difficile mais revenons sur Sainte
Soline faut pas nous prendre pour des
enfants du bon Dieu comme ça ça joue le
conseiller je fais un peu ce registre ce
matin non mais attendez tout le monde a
vu ce qui s'est passé là-bas il y a eu
des violences organisées avec des gens
camouflés armés parfois etc et est-ce
que vous avez entendu marine tondeelier
dire quoi que ce soit même avec le recul
sur le coup elle avait rien dit mais
est-ce que vous avez entendu marine
Tondelier prendre des distances avec
cela c'est ça qui est en cause tout à
l'heure c'est une parce que justement
elle a dit elle a reconnu qu'il y avait
eu des violences de part et d'autre qui
ne sont pas le fait des associations qui
étaient présentes et qui était
organisatrice le problème
mon cher Dominique maître
pardon je me suis faute de langage elle
l'a fait plein de fois et d'autres qui
étaient sur place n'ont fait plein de
fois y compris les élus écologistes de
la France insoumise socialiste qui était
présent avec les armes les armes là où
je trouve que vous faites dans le de
poids de mesure c'est que vous rendez
compte quand même là il y a une
mobilisation qui date de plus de 30 ans
sur les questions de Mega bassine avec
une initiative qui est une initiative
coordonnée de plusieurs associations qui
sont connues de des Français qui sont
connus au niveau local pour être des
organisations qui lancent des alertes
sur des sujets écologistes et qui
organise une manifestation on annonce
30000 personnes et là il y a le muse
l'intérieur qui dit on interdit bah oui
il y a un problème de démocratie
pourquoi sur une mobilisation sur un
terrain vague on devrait interdire vous
prenez des mobilisations
j'ai fait des mobilisations je peux vous
assurer que moyen de police mieux ça se
passe et c'est le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que plus il y a de la police plus
vous générez de l'attention mais
d'ailleurs plus vous générez de la
tension non mais c'est l'histoire
Dominique c'est pas non c'est pas c'est
pas tant ça je suis désolé je vous
invite à venir aux manifestations et aux
mobilisations
je le reconnaissez beaucoup alors moi je
n'étais pas à Sainte-Souline j'en ai
fait deux de démobilisations écologistes
je suis allé en tant que journaliste
mais je peux vous assurer que moi il y a
de policiers moi il y a de tension dans
les dans les dans les mobilisations donc
c'est aussi ça le problème c'est que à
un moment donné quand on met 3000
policiers sur une mobilisation comme
celle-ci il y a une disproportion de
l'action militante c'est pour ça que je
dis qu'on doit tous s'inquiéter sur la
possibilité le lieu de la répression de
des mobilisation quel est votre petit
commentaire après coup ou grands
commentaires sur Lyon sur Lyon sur un
bah écoutez c'est pareil là on a on a on
a laissé les les
occuper des lieux
occuper les rails occupés si vous voulez
mais c'est pas que les écolos vous il y
a plein de citoyens qui considèrent les
étapes sur mais c'est pas que
d'aujourd'hui ça fait 30 ans que c'est
raconté cette histoire que le lion Turin
est une absurdité est une incohérence
écologique sans nom laissons les gens
s'exprimer quand il y a besoin de
s'exprimer pourquoi on devrait interdire
des mobilisations
qui vont dans ces manifestations avec
des intentions passifs mais ça c'est le
rôle de la préfecture et c'est le rôle
du ministère de l'Intérieur de faire en
sorte que c'est agents qui ont vocation
à commettre des violences de les
intercepter en amont ou en tout cas sur
place mais non parce qu'en plus je dis
ça mais je suis contre c'est illégal
c'est illégal mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on sait les reconnaître au
moment où il y a un passage
sur le territoire à vouloir tout
interdire il y a et l'accélération de ce
que j'ai de ce que j'ai voulu
mais non mais c'est pas c'est ça le
problème de Lyon Turin Lyon Turin encore
une fois vous avez ce Français qui a été
arrêté oui interdiction active du
territoire souvenez-vous de ce n'est pas
le problème c'est probablement de suite
c'est une erreur je sais pas bon vous
allez pas tout ramener l'affaire de Lyon
Turin qui est une affaire énorme vous
savez vous savez vous savez pourquoi ce
jeune Français les Italiens qui
l'accompagnaient ont été arrêté sur le
sur le trajet vitalité
sainte Soline donc maintenant à partir
du moment où vous allez participer à une
manifestation comme le jeune dont Marine
ton allait parler qui avait soit disant
participé à l'action contre la
cimenterie là-bas Lafarge a été arrêtée
perquisitionnée donc on va prendre vous
êtes suspecté d'avoir une manifester
manifester une mobilisation vous irez à
une autre bah vous serez interdit
d'aller manifester vous serez pas
conditionné vous trouvez ça normal mais
franchement on est en France je trouve
pas normal ce que je trouve
la montée la montée d'une violence
explicite revendiquée et qui n'est pas
battu par des organisations qui elles
pourtant ne se réfère pas à la violence
il y a un problème vous avez écouté
marine tomber comme moi ce matin elle
dénonce les violences elle dénonce
une quinzaine de secondes qui sont de
bonnes à loin
vous exagérez et par ailleurs les
premières victimes
les premières victimes parlent un peu
plus spontanément un peu plus de façon
un peu plus calme première victime comme
ça première victime de ces violences
c'est avant tout les organisateurs les
gens qui se mobilent qui se manifestent
mais il y a Pacifique ce sont les
policiers mais bon
elle n'aura jamais lieu pour vous la
dissolution
vous êtes d'accord ça va être compliqué
de dissoudre les soulèvements de la
terre
mais ça va être compliqué
[Musique]